HOLOCAUST REMEMBRANCE DAY.
LET'S WATCH MOST TRUSTED AND YOU
SPENT THE EVENING WITH WITH US.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND.
>> GOOD EVENING AND WELCOME TO
PATH TO CITIZENSHIP.
MANY THAT BROKE OUR LAWS TO GET
HERE WOULD RECEIVE AMNESTY.
VERY FEW SUPPORTERS WANTED THAT
AND ARE UPSET.
THE LEFT, THEIR REACTION?
HAVING GOT WHAT THEY DEMANDED,
THEY'RE ENRAGED.
NOT ONLY IS THE AMNESTY NOT
ENOUGH, THEY SAY IT IS A RACIST
PLOT.
THE ACLU SAYS THE ONLY PEOPLE
THAT BENEFIT IS WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
PHILOSOPHY IN THE WHITE HOUSE
WAS RACIST AND WAS SAID TO BE A
BURNING CROSS.
>> THE PRESIDENT PUT TOGETHER A
PLAN TO MAKE AMERICA WHITE
AGAIN.
THEY'RE CHANGING THE CHARACTER
OF OUR COUNTRY BY WHAT THEY'RE
PUTTING FORTH.
THEY BRING A TEAR TO THE EYE OF
THE STATUE OF LIBERTY AND THEY
BRING FEAR TO THE HEARTS THAT
PEOPLE ARE HERE PLAYING BY THE
RULES.
>> WE COULD GO ON AND ON AND
ON.
IT IS EVERYWHERE TODAY.
THEY'RE TELLING YOU THIS IS
SOMETHING THE KLAN COULD HAVE
PRODUCED.
WE DECIDED TO LOOK AT WHAT THE
WHITE HOUSE HAS ACTUALLY
PROPOSED.
THE PLAN MAY BE MANY THINGS, NOT
ALL GOOD, BUT IT DEFINITELY IS
NOT A FORM OF WHITE NATIONALISM
UNLESS THAT TERM HAS OPPOSITE
MEANING.
IT WOULD LEGALIZE 2 MILLION
PEOPLE THAT CURRENTLY ARE NOT
LEGALLY HERE.
THAT'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
CURRENTLY 13 STATES HAVE POP
CURRENTLY 13 STATES HAVE PO
POPULATIONS THAN THAT.
HOW MANY OF THOSE BENEFICIARIES
ARE WHITE?
THAT WOULD BE THE CENTRAL
QUESTION IN THIS PLAN CRAFTED BY
WHITE SUPREMACIST.
2 MILLION NONBE WHITE PEOPLE,
THAT'S MORE THAN THE POPULATION
OF DELAWARE AND NEBRASKA.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A BURNING
CROSS.
LOST MORE.
THE PROPOSAL WOULD CONTINUE THE
CURRENT SYSTEM OF MIGRATION
UNTIL THE BACK LOG IS EXHAUSTED
WHICH WOULD BE YEARS.
WHAT WOULD BE THE ARRANGEMENT
UNDER THE TRUMP PLAN.
IF YOU CONSIDER FINLAND AND
NORWAY AND OTHERS, NO EUROPEAN
COUNTRY IS ON THE LIST.
THE PLAN WOULD ADMIT A MILLION
MORE IMMIGRANTS FROM MEXICO AND
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS FROM
INDIA.
THE PHILIPPINES TOO.
IT WOULD BRING ADDITIONAL
IMMIGRANTS FROM HAITI, THE PLACE
THE PRESIDENT SUPPOSEDLY HATES.
NO MATTER WHAT THE RACE BAITERS
ARE TELLING YOU.
A WHITE NATIONALIST PLOT, IN THE
HISTORY OF DUMB TALKING POINTS,
THAT MAY BE THE DUMBEST OF ALL.
IT IS POISONOUS TOO.
IT MAKES PEOPLE HATE EACH OTHER
AND FURTHER DIVIDES THE COUNTRY.
ER WE DON'T NEED MORE OF THAT.
THE PEOPLE REPEATING IT SHOULD
THEY NEED TO KNOW THEIR LINE.
MAYBE THEY DON'T KNOW.
MAYBE THEY CONVINCED THEMSELVES
THE RHETORIC IS TRUE.
IT IS POSSIBLE THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS INSANE.
THEY SAY IT IS IMMORAL TO
RESTRICT IMMIGRATION FROM ANY
COUNTRY IN ANY AMOUNT FOR ANY
REASON EVER.
EVEN ENFORCING OUR OWN EXISTING
LAWS, THE ONES THEY VOTED FOR
AND PASSED IN CONGRESS IS TANT
MOUNT TO A HATE CRIME.
THE PUBLIC DOESN'T AGREE WITH
ANY OF THIS, SO BY DEFINITION,